we should have this program warning nard
snipe warning yeah so you are often a
victim of nerd sniping nerd sniping
being of course seeing some interesting
usually hypothetical question posted
somewhere on the internet that someone's
like how many you know what would happen
if you had a planet made of blueberries
for example and then you go and actually
calculate it and you actually wrote a
paper on this particular question right
yes I did
so this began on physics Stack Exchange
which is a site I'm kind of my plenty to
do so now I live that area somebody post
this question and I started writing an
answer and then the moderators close to
question because it was silly I got so
upset so I decided I'm totally going to
calculate this and put it on my own blog
and then I realize actually I can turn
this into a proper paper so now I'm
working on resubmitting into a journal
it's like the tricky to find journals
for take papers about the astrophysics
of berries but I'm working on it and so
what is if you can summarize what
happens to a planet so imagine or
suddenly turning into blueberries know
you have a lot of blueberries and
between them air and gravity goes down
of course because blueberries are light
approach however the pressure at the
core is pretty big enough to pout a
little Bluebird so they stop compressive
so now you get bubbles of air going up
and a lot of blueberry pop going down so
the whole planet compresses about 700
kilometres that's all that's all that's
not that much it's kind of innocent yeah
it's a pretty good feeling fraction
however now you have a lot of mass
moving inwards several hundred
kilometres and a lot of air moving out
so this heats things up so you basically
at a boiling ocean of blueberry jam with
gazers throwing stuff up
far into this steam atmosphere in a
steam atmosphere
yeah because there's a lot of water in
those blueberries right so you end up
with is a blueberry jam ocean but the
pressure at the cool
is high enough to create high-pressure
ice most likely so you get the kind of
granite decor inside yeah it would be
also what happens is that the moon moves
away because Earth's gravity disappears
to a large example but it's still moving
in an orbit in the vicinity of sooner or
later it's likely to collide with
blueberry earth and splatter blueberries
all over the solar system why would it
come closer
well the moon is the earth-crossing
orbits so given the perturbations for
other planets I think it's pretty likely
but eventually I believe it's kind of
funny because the moon started with a
mars-sized planet slamming into Earth
most likely and then the moon forming of
the remnants and now we might have a
moon returning and splattering a
blueberry jam over a solar system thanks
for watching folks if you enjoyed this
then make sure you click that subscribe
button below because well you wouldn't
want to miss out on any future videos
now would you